porque rechaza el grueso de los
opositores los comicios legislativos del
6 de diciembre el no participar en estas
votaciones es la edición correcta para
la oposición
la oposición rechaza más que la posición
las fuerzas democráticas de la sociedad
que son incluso más más amplias que la
propia oposición rechazan de plano de
esta convocatoria al 6 de diciembre
porque se trata de una convocatoria que
es por un lado ilegal porque viola la
ley electoral que impide hacer cambios a
la norma en los seis meses que preceden
a una elección pero esta y ésta se
hicieron unos cambios muy profundos
antes de ese periodo pero aún más grave
que esto es es una convocatoria
inconstitucional pues en dibuja un
parlamento que es distinto al que
expresa la constitución y unas reglas de
elección y de representación distintas a
las expresadas por la constitución pero
además de eso es propia el derecho al
voto directo de las poblaciones
indígenas que es muy grave y confisca
además el derecho a voto y a la
representación política de los 5
millones de venezolanos que son aunque
están en el exilio y son parte
amplísima diáspora que está por todo el
mundo que no están teniendo derecho a
votar en este proceso profesora de esta
consulta que promueve juan guaidó y la
oposición preguntará a los venezolanos
si rechazan estas parlamentarias también
solicita a la comunidad internacional su
desconocimiento cómo deben responder los
actores internacionales y puede tener
algún peso esta consulta opositora nos
quedan sólo unos 45 segundos
bueno rapidísimo es una consulta que
evidentemente no sustituye en ningún
proceso electoral porque cualquier
proceso electoral debe ser basado en un
amplio consenso eso es lo que define un
proceso electoral más que más que la
elección en sí es que la base sea
producto de un consenso eso no lo cubre
ni ni la elección ni esta convocatoria
al 66 pero tampoco lamentablemente la
consulta que simplemente una muestra de
descontento ante lo que se considera una
convocatoria ilegal e inconstitucional